es ist ein versprechen das wir von bild
gegeben haben wir schauen bei
kindesmissbrauch hin
wir berichten immer darüber und wir
lassen täter und mit verantwortlichen
nicht so einfach davonkommen
und auch jetzt berichten wir wieder über
den fall den tragischen fall des kleinen
luca er schläft scheinbar glücklich und
friedlich der kleine luca ein foto wie
von millionen babys doch luca wurde nur
acht monate alt sein leben nicht
glücklich nicht friedlich sondern ein
martyrium aus gewalt sein vater
christian h drogenabhängig er soll luca
mit einer fernbedienung zu tode
geprügelt haben
erst dann habe luca aufgehört zu weinen
todesursache hirnblutungen
christian h hatte noch versucht die tat
zu vertuschen luca sei die treppe runter
gefallen sagte er der polizei
unverzeihlich das jugendamt kannte die
problematische familie war mehrfach bei
luca zu hause doch die beamten schritten
auch nicht ein als sie bei luca zeichen
von misshandlung fest stellten eine
beule am kopf nämlich und das war zwei
tage vor lukas tot
fakt ist der zuständigen behörde war
bekannt dass der vater drogen nahm
gewalttätig gegen lucas mutter war und
dennoch sah die behörde keinen anlass
das baby in ihre obhut zu nehmen
bild sprach nun mit lucas mutter sie
ließ lucca alleine mit ihren
gewalttätigen vater zu bild sagt sie
ich vermute er luca absichtlich getötet
damit ich ihn nicht zu mir holen kann
ich kann auch nicht verstehen weshalb
das amt mein kind bei einem vater der
gewalttätig ist lassen konnte
bisher wollte uns das jugendamt im
rhein-neckar-kreis keine antworten geben
aber auch hier gilt unser versprechen
wir bleiben aktiv dran